[Música]
muy buenos días bienvenidos estas son
las noticias más destacadas hasta esta
hora de la mañana aquí en france 24
comenzamos en españa donde ya fueron
puestos en libertad los 9 líderes
separatistas catalanes que el día de
ayer fueron indultados tras una votación
en una sesión del consejo de ministros
los 9 separatistas estaban acusados de
delitos de malversación y sedición por
el proceso independentista llevado a
cabo en 2017 su indulto fue propuesto
por el presidente del gobierno español
pedro sánchez quien definió su
liberación como una vía para recuperar
la concordia con la comunidad autónoma
catalana una liberación que según el
mismo sánchez tiene condiciones con la
justicia española una comitiva del
partido esquerra republicana de
catalunya ha recibido a los liberados
que también fueron recibidos por el
presidente de la generalitat de
catalunya pere aragonès las
excarcelaciones han contado también con
un fuerte rechazo por parte de los
conservadores que anunciaron que van a
recurrir a recursos judiciales para
revertir esta medida
carme forcadell
ex miembro del parlamento catalán y una
de las excarceladas dio algunas
declaraciones a los medios escuchemos
nosaltres al que volem es la amnistía
hoy es un día de alegría de alegría
especialmente las que han surgido de la
presión pedal en nuestras familias pero
la alegría no es completa no es porque
nosotros lo que volvemos la fide la
represión que todas las personas
represaliadas en su día al carrer con
nosotros libremente en chepo arrestos
exiliado gent urna en otros temas el
apple daily el principal diario pro
democrático de la ciudad autónoma de
hong kong anunció que dejará de
publicarse de manera impresa y dejará de
actualizar su página web esta misma
semana un hecho que tiene lugar sólo un
año después de que beijing impusiera la
ley de seguridad en la antigua colonia
británica desde beijing a adrián
foncillas nos tiene más detalles en su
reporte cierra el periódico más
fragoroso y popular de hong kong la
directiva del apple daily anunciaba hoy
que este fin de semana lanzará su última
edición en papel
a su página web la decisión llegaba
pocas horas después de conocerse que
había sido detenido su jefe de
editoriales por la autoría de cinco
artículos en los que se pedía la
adopción de sanciones internacionales
para hong kong esos artículos son según
la nueva ley de seguridad nacional
constitutivos del delito de colusión con
fuerzas extranjeras y había motivado la
detención en los últimos días de otros
cinco altos directivos del diario 'el
apple daily simboliza la división de la
sociedad con conesa para unos es un
paladín de la libertad para otros es un
tabloide infame el periódico
sensacionalista y sexista no ha sido
ajeno a los escándalos desde que naciera
veinte años atrás por ejemplo con la
publicidad que asemejaba a los chinos
del interior con plagas de langostas que
asolaban hong kong también ha sido el
mayor defensor de las protestas de los
últimos años su desaparición en
cualquier caso es una terrible noticia
para la libertad de prensa de hong kong
y mientras la región decide ama en el
sur de etiopía retomaba la votación de
las elecciones parlamentarias organismos
humanitarios y testigos denunciaron un
ataque aéreo contra un mercado en la
población
en la región de tigre y en donde decenas
de personas fallecieron y damas retomo
sin contratiempos la votación este
martes después de que la autoridad
electoral reconociera su error al
empaquetar y enviar solo la mitad de las
papeletas de votación necesarias sin
embargo estos comicios quedaron opacados
por la noticia de este ataque aéreo en
la región de tigray allí personal médico
en el lugar dijo que un avión soltó una
bomba sobre este mercado y se reportan
entre 50 y 80 víctimas fatales muchos
heridos también parte de este personal
médico dijo que se les había impedido el
acceso a la zona hasta el momento no hay
una confirmación oficial sobre este
hecho
es todo por el momento en 30 minutos una
nueva actualización de noticias en
france 24 siga con nosotros buenos días